GOT THE VERY LAST
GOVERNMENT-ISSUED SEX KIT HERE.
- OH, COOL.
- OKAY.
I KNOW SEX
CAN BE SCARY SOMETIMES.
SO THIS WILL HELP YOU
MAKE IT FUN AND SAFE.
HERE'S A MAPLE-FLAVORED
DENTAL DAM.
IT ALSO GLOWS IN THE DARK.
THAT'S IF YOU WANT TO PERFORM
SOME CUNNILINGUS,
AND YOU CAN ALSO
TRY RIMMING.
HERE'S A VIBRATOR FOR YOU.
WE'VE GOT THE BUTT PLUG
AS WELL.
CAN USE IT
FOR SOMEONE'S EXIT.
- IT LOOKS LIKE A SQUID.
- DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR ME, MICHAEL?
- WHAT IF
I'M NOT GOOD AT SEX?
OR WHAT IF
I'M SO GOOD AT IT,
I BECOME OBSESSED WITH IT?
OR WHAT IF IT'S SOMETHING
I DON'T EVEN KNOW?
I GUESS IT JUST ALL
FEELS SO COMPLICATED.
- WELL, I WOULD TRY
THE BUTT PLUG.
YEAH.
- COOL.
- ONE THING,
I WOULD RECOMMEND USING
SOME OTHER PROPHYLACTICS,
UNLESS YOU WANNA
END UP LIKE YOUR FRIEND
TOONS OVER THERE.
- BREATHE IT ON OUT.
BREATHE IT ON OUT, TOONS.
AND BREATHE OUT.
AND GOOD.
THAT SLIMY
LITTLE BUTTERBALL'S
GONNA DROP RIGHT OUT OF YOU.
[chuckles]
- OH, HEY, MIKEY.
- OH, HEY, TOONS.
HEY, COACH TEACHER.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING DOWN HERE?
- OH, I'M NOT JUST
A WHIRLING COACH.
I ALSO COACH CANADIAN LAMAZE.
- AND HE'S THE FATHER.
- OH, HOW FAR ALONG
ARE YOU, TOONS?
- TEN MONTHS.
- OH, SO YOU GOT TIME.
- WELL, MWAH.
GOTTA GO TO THE CAFETORIUM,
WORK MY SHIFT AT
THE JUNIOR NEEDLE EXCHANGE.
YOU BE GOOD,
YOU BE GOOD.
- THANKS FOR STICKING AROUND,
MIKEY.
- OH, I GOTTA GO.
PEACE OUT, TOONS.
- PEACE OUT.
- HEY, COLLETTE,
I DON'T KNOW
IF WE'VE EVER FORMALLY
BEEN INTRODUCED,
BUT MY NAME'S MIKEY.
- GOSH, I THOUGHT
YOUR NAME WAS LEGS.
- OH, NO, THAT'S
MY CASUAL GOOF NAME
THAT EVERYONE CALL ME
'CAUSE THEY HATE ME.
- WELL, YOU JUST TELL THEM
TO HUSH UP.
- MAYBE I WON'T BE SO HARSH,
BUT I'LL DO THAT.
- SAY, I'D LOVE TO STAY
AND CHAT, EH,
BUT I HAVE MINUTES
TO PROOFREAD, SO--
- OH, NO DOUBT,
NO DOUBT.
HEY, I WAS WONDERING,
COLLETTE,
WOULD YOU BE GAME
TO BEING MY PARTNER
AT THE MAPLE GAMES TONIGHT?
- OF COURSE I WILL.
I'LL SEE YOU THERE.
- OH, COOL.
- PARDON ME.
- AWESOME.
THAT'S REALLY EXCITING.
- OH, PARDON ME.
- PARDON.
I GUESS I'VE GOT A DATE--
A DATE WITH INTERCOURSE.